pink gets candid about her past crushes
on carpool karaoke it was the first time
someone ever broke my heart
[Music]
the beautiful trauma singer appeared on
The Late Late Show with James Corden
Tuesday and opened up about her first
heartbreak I ripped his posters off the
wall threw them out and didn't come out
of my room for days pink was seven when
she learned her celeb crush Jon Bon Jovi
tied the knot I was devastated
a decade later pink got the chance to
meet Bon Jovi and confessed her
childhood feelings later the living on a
prayer singer sent her a gift with a
funny card the flower basket was like
life-size yeah and there was a pair of
leather pants with a note that said now
you can finally get into my pants
but Pink's hobby Carey Hart didn't
exactly appreciate the gesture Harry
threw them out the window the 38 year
old also opened up about her one-time
date with NSYNC Joey Fatone he was such
a sweetheart
at the time pink was on tour with a boy
band and he asked her dad for permission
to take her out and he took me to
friendlies oh you did come on we went to
friendlies as a friendly date not like a
date day I think Joey didn't bring that
as a friendly day we were in the friend
zone
[Music]